Clara, gestern Abend hätt' ich dich fast angerufen, ich war betrunken und hätte es nicht machen sollen. Doch im letzten Moment hab' ich mich Gott sei Dank dagegen entschieden. Clara, du fehlst mir sehr. Das Ganze mal auf Spotify hochklassen. Oh mein Gott, das ist mir mega unangenehm. Hey, herzlich willkommen. Wie toll war das denn jetzt? Sie hörten gerade Stephans neue Single. Mittlerweile nutzt er unser Intro als Werbeplattform für seine neue, verschiedene Single. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Ihr habt gehört am Schlagzeug Patrick Zwo. Patrick Zwo? Ja. Vielen Dank an Patrick für das fantastische Intro. Das ehrt mich jetzt sehr, weil da habe ich einen Song improvisiert, niemand hat darüber in Musik geschrieben. Das hast du wirklich schön gemacht. Gibt es Clara Teil zwei? Ich erinnere mich an nichts, was da passiert ist, besungen wurde. Und ich dachte auch, eigentlich dir angesehen zu haben, dass du auch nicht genau weißt, wie die Folge, dass es kommt. Aber total schön. Du bist dann so ein bisschen wie Lenny Kravitz im Interview dann so, ja, hello, worauf bezieht sich das? Also, was geht da emotional in Ihnen vor? I have no idea. Also diese enormen Emotionen, woher kommen die, von welcher Quelle zehren sie da? Ich weiß nicht mehr, das war irgendwann in den Achtzigern oder so was habe ich geschrieben.
Weiss ich nicht, ich weiss nichts mehr.
Vielleicht weil ich Leute auf der Strasse begrüsst habe, oder weiss ich nicht.
An wen richtet sich das? Also ist das ein Hello, das nach innen geht?
Weiss ich nicht. Also es ist ein, es ist vor allem Hello, aber ich will jetzt nicht zu viel reininterpretieren.
Aber was fühlen Sie, wenn Sie es heute singen auf der Bühne? Also wovon zehren Sie da?
Wenig, wenig, Geld. Das Geld, was ich bekomme für die Leute, die die Eintrittskarten gezahlt haben. Weiß ich nicht. Gut, wir machen kurze Werbung und sind dann zurück zu einem vierstündigen Interview mit Leonard Kravitz, der heute macht. Leonard. Leonard Kravitz. Leo, ab dem gewissen Punkt muss man entweder länger oder kürzer werden in der Geschichte eines Künstlers. Irgendwann musst du länger werden oder kürzer werden. Ja, ja. Und du? Ich glaube, ich werde noch länger, um dann wieder ganz kurz zu werden. Und dann nur noch, ja, ich, man nennt mich jetzt nur noch F. Nee, von diesem FDP-Image versuche ich ein bisschen wegzukommen. Aber, Florentin, David, Pascal, ja, es ist nicht das Beste. Da glaube ich, haben meine Eltern auch nicht mitgedacht. Ich glaube, du musst immer, wenn du so Mittelnamen, so J.R.R. Tolkien, J.R.R.R.R. da darf er da nicht so KFC Tolkien oder so rauskommen am Ende. Kendrick Fitzgerald Charles Tolkien und alle nennen ihn nur noch KFC Tolkien und so. K.P.M.G. Tietze. Nee, das ist ein bisschen nicht genau. M.F.G. Schmidt. Das Einfach nicht cool, wenn dann einfach so was rauskommt. LG Stephan finde ich nicht so schlecht. Aber mir gefällt, bei FDP ist es so ein bisschen, es ist immer vom politischen Klima gerade abhängig. Stimmt. Weil es gibt sicherlich auch mal, es gab Zeiten in der Geschichte, wo das ein guter Name, FDP will ein guter Name ist. Es sind wie Aktien, sie fallen und steigen, aber man muss sich festhalten, als wären sie sein eigen eigenes Kind. Sehr gut, vielen, vielen Dank, Patrick hat das tolle Intro komponiert. Du hast das gut gemacht, du hast aus einem sehr wertvollen Marmorstein eine noch schönere Marmorstatue geklopft. Man braucht beides, das Material muss gut sein, aber die handwerkliche Schaffenskraft muss auch gut sein. Nur gute Zutaten reichen nicht. Das wird ihm sehr wichtig sein, auch jetzt, dass von zwei Leuten, die musikalisch keine Ahnung haben, da jetzt das Lob kommt und so und die jetzt seine handwerkliche Schaffenskraft loben, würde ihm jetzt zu Hause sehr viel bedeuten wahrscheinlich. Aber wahnsinnig cool. Super cool. Das habe ich auch noch einmal gemacht. Ich habe auch mal, ich schaue einen Twitch-Stream sehr gern und habe da, da wurde auch ein Song improvisiert und darauf habe ich auch dann mal so ein bisschen, weil es auch einen Community-Aufruf gab, nee, keinen Beat gelegt, aber so ein bisschen so ein Musiktheater, Musical-Song drüber komponiert. Cool. Ich habe die Musik wieder für mich entdeckt und habe das natürlich die ganze Zeit mit dem Wissen gemacht, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht gespielt wird, jemals. Und es wurde auch nicht gespielt und dann war ich sauer darüber. Ja, du weißt jetzt ja, wie es den hunderten Leuten gibt, die im Intro Papierkorb schlummern und einfach noch
auf ihren Durfbruch warten. Ja, total. Ich konnte
mit allen Relaten da draußen, die noch nicht gespielt wurden.
Und das ist total ärgerlich und doof.
Und auch wir sind doof, wenn wir immer sagen,
wenn wir Witze über das Intro machen.
Eigentlich müssten wir immer uns zehn Minuten
Zeit nehmen und irgendwie die Schaffenskraft
loben. Patrick Zwo, du hast das gut gemacht.
Stefan Tietze hört sich selbst.
Beste Patrick. Der mit Abstand beste Patrick. Patrick Zwo? Patrick Eins war ja gemacht, Stefan Tietze hört sich selbst, das hat er gut gemacht. Der mit Abstand Beste Patrick.
Patrick Zwo? Patrick Eins war er, wissen wir alle.
Wir machen mal Top Fünf Patricks.
Okay. Also,
auf Platz Fünf, Patrick Nuo.
One, two, three, four,
five days, once
in a lifetime. Mega Song.
Supergut.
Too good to be true, the universe
is passing by, but I can't forget, I want you to brave.
Supergeil. Hättest du lieber einen One-Hit-Wonder, der richtig gross geht und danach nie wieder einen Erfolg oder durchgehend so Mittelerfolg, so durchgehend so 200 Leute Publikum? Nee, lieber einen richtigen Erfolg, dann so alles mitnehmen. Drogenskandal, Sexskandal, alles mitnehmen, um dann in der Versenkung ewig auch vergessen zu werden. Aber es ist auch nicht so schlimm, dass die Skandale aufhauchen, weil du einfach nicht so wichtig bist für die Popkultur. Ja, das stimmt. Du kannst danach relativ einfach untertauchen. Ich glaube, Patrick, nur wenn der heute bei Lidl an der Kassisch einkauft. Wird in Ruhe gelassen. Der wird in Ruhe gelassen. Also anders als jetzt, sagen wir mal, andere Patrick, Patrick Stewart oder sowas, die kaum noch einkaufen gehen können. Werden in Lidls belagert. Die können kaum noch einen Fuss in Lidl setzen, das geht nicht. Die sind froh, wenn Kasse 3 aufgeht, dann sage ich dir ganz ehrlich, dann rennen die da hin und werden nicht belagert. Nee, Patrick Nuo kann glaube ich ganz ruhigen Gewissens Liebe Grüße an der Stelle auch nochmal. Gehen raus. Das kannst du nicht machen. Kommen sie an, das weiss ich nicht. Du sagst immer Leuten, wir grüßen niemanden im Podcast. Und dann zwei Folgen später grüßt du Patrick Nuo. Da habe ich mich selber nicht an meine Regeln gehalten. Da war ich einfach zu verführt schnell. Gut, verstehe ich auch. Patrick Nummer vier, Patrick Star aus SpongeBob Schwammkopf. Guter Patrick, aber nicht einer der besten Patricks. Man kann sagen, was jemandem Intellekt fehlt, macht er durch Loyalität und Spaß wieder wett. Absolut, absolut. Und seitdem frage ich mich tatsächlich immer, wenn ich einen Seestern sehe, wo ist oben, wo ist unten? Gibt's Beine, gibt's Arme? Rede ich gerade vielleicht mit dem Arm? Also stelle ich mich gerade vor dem falschen Körperteil? Ich würde an deiner Stelle noch einen Schritt zurückgehen. Warum rede ich mit diesem Seestern? Aber das ist jetzt du. Es ist erstmal die Frage, wo ist hinten, wo ist vorne, so da kommen wir erstmal die drei Dinge in die Detail. Das sieht man aber, das sieht man schnell. Das sieht man schnell. Unten sind die ganz vielen Füsschen. Und dann musst du halt einfach mit deiner 20% Leben, deiner Chance, vielleicht rede ich gerade mit dem Bein, vielleicht gebe ich gerade dem Gesicht die Hand, so es kann sein. Entschuldigung, Sie reden mit dem Arm. Oh Gott, das tut mir leid.
Nee, weil ich beobachte sie jeden Tag, wie sie hier
ins Aquarium kommen und, ähm, gut,
ich bin nur draußen, ich bin nur der Türsteher, okay?
Aber ich sehe sie jeden Tag hier reinkommen
und mit dem Seestern reden, sie reden immer mit dem Arm.
Das ist der Arm? Das ist der Arm, ja.
Aber was sind das denn für zwei Flecken dann da drauf?
Ich dachte, das sind die auch. Das sind nur Leberflecken.
Ach so, okay.
Muttermale, oder was? Das sind zwei Muttermale. Ach jetzt. Mutter-Se heisst, ich habe mein ganzes Liebeskummer in Arm erzählt, oder was? Ich würde nochmal, also warum reden Sie denn so viel mit dem Seestern? Suchen Sie doch andere Menschen irgendwie. Weil ich habe Sie noch nie mit jemandem kommen sehen. Okay, also no offense oder sowas. Sie beobachten jetzt hier die Leute, die ins Aquarium reinkommen, oder was? Ja, ich habe nicht so viel zu tun. Mein einziger Job ist draußen, ich bin Türsteher von einem Aquarium. Wir lassen jeden rein, der Zahl. Aber lassen Sie auch jeden raus, ist die Frage. Wenn der Rochen jetzt raus sagt, so, ich gehe mal kurz für eine Kippe, ne? Sorry, ich komme mal wieder. Du, hey, pass mal auf, ich gehe mal kurz rein. Unter uns, die Rochen sind die schlimmsten. Die Rochen sind so Rabaukrochen. Die haben eine Rochenecke. Komm du, ich gehe mal kurz raus, ne, ich komm gleich später wieder rein. Die Rochenecke ist voll, immer. Und dann sag ich manchmal, nee, können jetzt nicht raus. Aber sonst, ich hab sie noch nie mit anderen Leuten reingeladen. Die kennen uns doch schon ewig, Mensch. Lass mich mal kurz raus, da ist doch gerade keiner da, Mensch. Alle reden mit Hamburger Slang, obviously. Nee, aber sie kommen nie mit anderen Leuten oder sowas und reden nie mit Menschen, sie reden nur mit Seesternen. Ne, wissen Sie, Seesterne hören mir zu. Die meisten Leute, mit denen ich rede, die gehen irgendwann weg, wissen Sie, seit ich Clara nicht mehr bei mir in meinem Leben habe und ich schreibe jeden Tag. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schreiben soll. Ist Clara ein Mensch? Clara ist eine Seegurke, aber trotzdem. Wo wollen sie hin? Wo wollen sie hin? Ging ist sie auch noch? Es ist ein harter Job. Seegurke. Seegurke, furchtbar. Aber mir gefallen Seeständer eigentlich ganz gut. Ich finde, die haben viel richtig gemacht. Die haben diese Gimmickness, haben es zum Pokémon geschafft. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Pokémon viel Erwartungshaltung aufbaut, die die Tiere nicht erfüllen können. Also ich glaube, das Image der Tiere im Allgemeinen wurde nachträglich zerstört durch Pokémon, weil Kinder denken, wow, Starmie, der kann Wasser schiessen. Mama, Mama, wo kann der den Wasser rausschießen? Nee, der liegt nur da. Der liegt einfach im Wasser. Das ist ja auch eine gute Fähähigkeit, im Wasser zu liegen und atmen zu können. Aber der kann Surfer, auf dem kann ich reiten und dann durch das Wasser fallen. Nein, nein, nein, Menschen können surfen, niemand, kein Tier kann surfen. Seestand kann generell auch nicht sich gut fortbewegen, also super langsam. Er hat große Schwierigkeiten, sich überhaupt zu drehen, auf die richtige Seite. Aber okay, dann soll er mal Stami-Stami sagen. Nein, die können nicht sein, nehmen nicht mal den Mund. Also vielleicht haben sie den Mund, aber das sieht man jetzt nicht. Moment mal, was sind dann diese vier Flecken dann da, wenn es kein Mund ist? Muttermale. Sehr gängig, sehr viel Missverständnis. Würdest du sagen, Pokémon haben A dazu beigetragen, dass Tiere ... Wie viele Antworten und Möglichkeiten werden? Ich muss meine Konzentration einteilen.
Das G.
G, okay.
Okay, alles klar.
Was ein bisschen daran liegt, dass ich nicht weiß,
wie viel die Buchstabe G ist gerade.
Der siebte, dann wird jetzt meine Aufmerksamkeit gesiebtet.
Los geht's.
Okay, also hast du das Gefühl, dass Pokémon A dazu geführt haben,
dass Kinder mehr Empathie Tieren entgegenbringen, B weniger, C deutlich mehr, D deutlich weniger. Warum ist diese Reihenfolge so? E ist mir egal. Keine Angabe, weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich nicht. Oben ist auch kein Sternchen, du musst diese Frage nicht beantworten. Okay. Wie viele Antworten kann ich geben?
Eine nur.
Ah, eine, okay.
F ist, du hast zu geringes Datenmaterial und G ist, Pokémon gehört abgeschafft.
Aber das gehört jetzt hier nicht hin.
Das ist die Argumentlichkeit.
Aber das gehört, glaube ich, jetzt hier nicht hin.
Das hat jetzt hier gar nichts zu suchen. Das ist hier nichts verloren zu suchen. Dann entscheide ich mich für E, weiß ich nichts. Okay. Ich glaube nämlich, dass Pokémon trotz allem, trotzdem Tiere dann vielleicht im direkten Vergleich langweiliger wirken, eher Positives getan haben für die Empathie gegenüber Tieren. Okay. Weil Leute haben also alle diese... Du hast die Frage hauptsächlich die die die die die die die die Geister-Pokémon sind? Was meinst du, wie die Geister-Pokémon sind? Mama, du kannst mir das auch normal erklären, ich hab nur gefragt. Was meinst du, was der Nebulak denn früher mal war, bevor es gestorben ist? Vielleicht war es ein kleines Hatfratz. Mama, Mama, Papa redet komisch mit mir, Papa! Mama! Was ist der mit dem Nebulak?
Und wer ist Knogger eigentlich? Wieso? Wessen Kopf trägt er auf seinem Schäl? Wessen Schäl hat er da? Deswegen gehen wir morgen ins Zoo und beschäftigen uns mit Tieren. Ja, dieser Pokémon-Quatsch, das hat völlig andere Eindrücke. So, gute Nacht. Nacht. Tür zugeschlagen. Allein da, das fände Allein das stelle ich mir so geil, wenn du ein Kind hast, liest eine Geschichte vor. Und sie lebten friedlich und freundlich bis ans Ende aller Tage. Gute Nacht. Wamm! Oma ist wahrscheinlich nicht im Himmel, sie ist einfach nur tot. Bamm! Jesus, Mama. Ah, sehr schön. Jesus, Mama. Das sind die besten Abgänge eigentlich, die aus dem Kinderzimmer. Einfach nochmal so, auch dieser Musicalblick nochmal raus und wamm. Ja, wir hatten zu alten, guten Arbeitszeiten, Sketch, Comedy, YouTube, kennt ihr nicht mehr. Es ist schon so lange her, dass man, glaube ich, noch Kontext liefern muss. Seit Jahren haben wir nicht mehr gedacht. Genau, da haben wir noch eine Tür gehabt. In unserem Writers' Room hatten wir eine Tür, die immer ein bisschen zu ausdrucksstark, stark zugegangen ist. Genau, die Tür war zu leicht. Die war so leicht, dass mit einer normalen Tür-Zumachkraft hat man sie zugeschlagen, weil sie einfach so wenig Widerstand gegeben hat. Sie sagt, ja, okay, bin zu, zack. Also bin ich rausgegangen, soll ich noch was von der Tankstelle mitbringen oder sowas? Ja, ich würde ein Kit-Kat-Junkie nehmen.
Alles klar, ich gehe raus und bam!
Und er ist so im Raum.
Was hat er gegen Junkie?
War er keine Kit-Kat-Junkie?
Ist das unsensibel?
Oder hätte man einfach sagen sollen, wollte er nichts mitbringen?
Moment, er hat nur aus Höflichkeit gefragt.
Und wir diskutieren die ganze Zeit.
Und währenddessen Stefan fröhlich läuft er, hoppserlau auf durch die Strassen, aber ich habe die Tür zugeschlagen und allen Leuten ging es so, irgendwann hat man sich daran gewöhnt, wir zumindest, und dann gingen unsere ZDF-Kollegen immer raus und haben die Tür zugeschlagen, aber bei denen, glaube ich, haben die es auch zugeschlagen. Das weiss man dann eben nicht, das kommt dann eben gar nicht mehr an, wenn man dann mal wütend abgeht und dann so, ja, das ist die Tür. Man hat weniger Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten, das ist schon schwierig. Nee. Aber hast du sowas zu Hause, irgendwie eine Tür, die weird ist oder sowas? Ich habe eine Tür, die wahnsinnig, die singt immer, die macht Melodie. Ja, genau. Macht man eine Tür. Wirklich? Ja. Aber hast du die mal stimmen lassen? Nee, kann man glauben. Weiß ich nicht, ob man das kann. Immer meine Klotür, wenn ich die aufmache, macht sie Okay. Daraufhin habe ich das eingespielt auf dem Klavier mal und einem Kumpel geschickt, erst das Video geschickt mit der Melodie und dann nochmal selber eingespielt und er hat daraus wirklich, da hat er auch Geigen drüber gelegt und sowas und der Ball liegt jetzt wieder bei mir und die Idee... Da liegt er jetzt erstmal. Und da liegt er lang, Leute.
Da liegt er schon zwei Jahre, glaube ich. Aber mein Ziel wäre daraus, irgendwann mal eine... Weil, bam, bam, bam, bam, ist ein sehr basic Anfang für eine Symphonie. Daraus wurden aber ganz, ganz tolle weitere Sätze für diese ganz tolle Symphonie. Ich glaube, es wäre ein guter Anfang für einen Musikschock, zum Beispiel eine Overtüre. Als Overtüre, aber. Ah, okay. Sorry, nee, ich habe es einfach nicht verstanden. Nee, ist schon in Ordnung. Wamm! Nee, es ist in Ordnung, kein Problem. Wenn du auf dem Klo bist,
wischst du dir den Penis ab?
Okay, lass uns noch mal ein paar Schritte zurückgehen.
Wir reden von Nummer eins und Nummer zwei.
Nummer eins.
Erstmal gefällt es mir, dass wir inzwischen an dem Punkt sind.
Ich meine, in anderen Freundschaften oder Partnerschaften
hat es länger,
redet man sehr schnell über diese Themen.
Wir haben sehr lange gebraucht.
Bei uns hat es sechs Jahre gebraucht. Und jetzt reden wir gebraucht und jetzt reden wir nur noch darüber. Ja, weil ich weiss, ich wollte einfach mal so einen Reality-Check machen. Okay, ich möchte Nummer eins und Nummer zwei. Nummer eins. Du pinkelst. Ja. Wird dann nochmal sozusagen abgewischt oder nicht? Abgeschüttelt? Vielleicht. Abgeschüttelt, aber Klopapier kommt ins Spiel, ja oder nein? Nein, okay. Reden wir von Pissoir oder Toilette? So, das ist nämlich genau der Unterschied. Weil ich habe es mir irgendwann angewöhnt, abzuwischen. Was? Und dann aber ist das Problem, wenn du am Pissoir stehst, dann hast du kein Papier da und dann gibt es Papier erst wieder am Waschbecken. Und dann gehe ich manchmal noch vom Pissoir zum Waschbecken.
Entblößt, sage ich mal.
Und das ist ein bisschen riskant.
Das ist nicht ein bisschen riskant, das ist glaube ich auch einfach.
Weil wenn da die Tür aufgeht.
Aber es ist noch nie passiert.
Ich versuche im Vorhinein zu überlegen.
Ich glaube nicht, aber es ist ein bisschen zu riskant.
Es ist... Aber es ist noch nie passiert. Ich versuche im Vorhinein zu überlegen. Ich weiß es nicht, ich glaube nicht, aber es ist ein bisschen zu riskant. Ich schaue gerade wieder viele Sitcoms und so, und dann denkt man ja so, wie kommen die auf diese ganzen Storys oder so. Und dann denke ich mir so, nee, das könnte eine Folge sein. So jemand kommt rein oder so, der Kollege oder der Chef, und dann redet man erst mal nicht drüber. Das ist ein sehr unschönen Vorfall.
Das ist ein sehr unschöner Vorfall, wie ich da so hingewackelt bin.
Und dann am nächsten Tag kommt man dann so ins Büro und meint so, ja, ähm, hm?
Nee, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Weil Sauberkeit ist ja echt A und O immer, auch Hygiene.
Voll, wie kommen Sie jetzt drauf?
Na, ich meine nur, ähm. Können Sie kurz mal die Quartalszahlen von ... Ja, schick's Ihnen rüber. 1948. Okay, ich schick's Ihnen rüber. Ja, danke schön. Ja, das war der Mail-Sound. Ja. Das Geräusch werdet ihr heute auch noch mal genau hören. Keine Sorge. Keine Sorge. Nee, ich meine ja nur, es ist ja auch wichtig, ähm ... Brrrr-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r- Warum Sie mich gestern so erwischt haben. Ich will gerne nicht mehr darüber reden. Okay, nur das. Genau, die Papiertücher sind am Waschbecken und. Sie wischen sich den Penis ab? Ja. Oder nicht. Das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Dieser. Ich meine, wenn man schüttelt, ist es halt, wann ist Schluss? Genau so jemanden brauche ich in dieser Firma. Wirklich? Jemand, der sich den Penis mit einem Papiertuch abwischt. Der so viel Wert auf die Teilgetreue legt, dass er sich sogar den Penis mit einem Papiertuch abwischt. Ja, weil ich denke, wenn du schüttelst, dann kommt ja nur mehr von innen nach. Das ist ja wie so eine Tube, wenn du die schüttelst, dann... Das ist eine Art Perpetuum mobile. Du verlagerst das Problem ja nur. Es geht ja um den Tropfen, der ganz vorne ist, wenn du den von hinten vorschüttelst. Und deswegen möchte ich sie gerne befördern. Ich finde, sie sind dem... Sie sollten eher Chef sein als ich. Wirklich? Ja. Dann bin ich jetzt der Chef von Pritt. Ja, Sie sind jetzt der Chef von Pritt. Von Zeva. Zeva wird schon weg. Wir werden Klebestifte ab jetzt anders machen als jemals zuvor. Und zwar, pass auf, Klebestift vorne und hinten. Okay. Du kannst den, weil ich mag es immer nicht, wenn du den Prittstift nimmst und du willst rausdrehen, aber du merkst, du hast ihn falschrum in der Hand und dann ihn umdrehen. Ab jetzt nicht mehr, geht in beide Richtungen. Oder ihn manchmal aufzudrehen, obwohl die Kappe noch drauf ist. Oh ja. Unschuldig. Du kannst ihn manchmal auch so aufdrehen, dass er die Kappe selbst löst. Oder vorne Prittstift, hinten Lippenstift. Alles super Ideen. Prippenstift. Prippenstift. Aber dann ist immer eine Seite raus, oder was? Er ist nie zu. Nicht unbedingt, nicht unbedingt, nicht unbedingt. Es gibt einen Mittelteil, wo er dann wirklich drin ist. Genau, ja, ja, ja. Okay. Und deswegen sind die der bessere Chef, merken Sie jetzt, wir haben jetzt schon mehr geleistet in den letzten zwölf Jahren. Als von 1948 bis jetzt haben wir schon mehr geleistet. Ich würde aber trotzdem sagen, dass unser Brett-Klebestoff immer noch nahezu wirkungslos ist. Ja, ja, gar nicht. Post-its
leisten mehr. Klebe-Wirkung
eins über menschlicher Spucke,
da würde ich bleiben. Auf Haarspray
steht ja unten immer diese Skala, eins bis fünf.
Ich bin großer Fan von
fünf, ultra starker Halt.
Habe ich jemals schon mal eine
zwei gesehen? Nein.
Fünf, ultra starker Halt ist
bei Haarspray, was man im
Laden kaufen kann, ist fünf ultra starke Halt überrepräsentiert, würde ich behaupten. Das ist so ein Ding wie den Nichtschutzfaktor. Eins hält kaum, habe ich so noch nie gesehen beim Haarspray. Eins einfach nur Wasser. Eins ist Spray. Einfach nur Wasser in einem Spray. Spray. Ja. Zwei ist, barely zu merken, drei ist, also ich verstehe nicht, warum ihr vier kauft, und vier ist ja gut, wenn ihr wollt, dass es abends leicht schlechter aussieht als morgen. Wer hat so präzise Anforderungen an die Klebkraft, dass man wirklich das auf einen genauen Faktor runterbringt? Ehrlich gesagt ich. Wirklich, aber kannst du nicht einfach die Menge variieren, einfach kurzer Stoss für wenig, langer Stoss für mehr? Das ist immer so das Ding. Ab wann geht's um Dauer und ab wann geht's um Menge? Das ist, kann mir da jemand, zum Beispiel Tee, du kannst ja Tee machen mit wenig Tee, aber lang drin lassen, oder viel Tee kurz drin, was ist die, so. Danke, danke, und deswegen hört ihr diesen Podcast, weil wir reden über die wichtigen Dinge. Weil ich bin der Meinung, stell dir mal vor, es gäbe auf Tees, schwarzer Tee, nur mal jetzt das Beispiel, gäbe es fünf Stärken und fünf wäre ultra starker Geschmack, dann wäre es ja genau das gleiche, dann hast du gerade einen wirklich guten Punkt gemacht. Ja, aber dann kaufe ich fünf... Weil es ist angenommen, ich kaufe fünf, fünf stärke fünf tee und macht dann aber nur drei minuten rein as opposed zu sechs minuten ja ja und oder haarspray ich benutze nur das dreier haarspray knallt mir aber alles damit voll ich glaube es aber weil irgendwann wird hier bitter und ich glaube wenn du also ich glaube dass es wenn du zu lange drin hast oder ich weiß auch nicht genau was das ist so dass ich finde T macht richtig, ich finde T macht richtig. Du hast diese Dimension nicht reingebaut, die du bei Haarspray aber hast. Diese Stärken sind doch unsinnig. Auch Distanz? Wie weit bist du weg von den Haaren? Na ja, gut, du hast ja einen Kegel. Du hast ja einen Sprühkegel, Stefan. Und jetzt kommt nochmal die ganz klassische Geometrie rein. Jetzt fangen wir noch an Geometrie rein. Ja, so und das glaube ich ist auch nochmal ein Faktor. Kann sein. Ich bin immer sehr, also ich verstehe nicht, warum es diese Skala genau gibt und so. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass man da einfach ein bisschen simplifiziert einfach vorgeht. Alles, jedes Haarspray hält maximal viel und gibt uns wieder, uns Menschen wieder ein bisschen Macht zurück. Total, es ist so, manche Entscheidungen will ich auch nicht treffen. Ich stehe auch immer ratlos vor dem Kühlschrank, wenn das heißt, ich will kühlen. Okay, kein Problem. Wollen Sie mit Stufe 1 kühlen? 2, 3, 4 oder 5? Kann ich nicht einfach die Temperatur einstellen? Nein, Sie müssen die Zahlen nennen. Aber wofür stehen die Zahlen? Die Stärke der Kälte. Die Stärke der Kälte. Die Kälte der Kälte. Also wie kalt ist die Kälte? Aber wir haben eine sehr gute Skala, die Temperaturmiss zum Beispiel. Hey, Samsung A5992, 3A-6. Ja, warum nicht Temperaturmiss? Ein, zwei, drei, vier oder fünf? Oder weiß ich nicht. Natürlich die drei. Es gibt kein Weiss ich nicht. Das sollte beim Kühlschrank mit drin sein, dieses Kein Weiss ich nicht. Mach du bitte. So eine I got you Stufe. Genau. Wir kriegen das hin. Oh, ich hatte jetzt einen interessanten Fall, weil ich habe ja schon mal erzählt, mein Kühlschrank und ich ist ein intensives Verhältnis, weil ich bin einige Tage der Woche nicht da in meiner Wohnung. Ach so, ich dachte in deinem Kühlschrank. Und deswegen mache ich den Kühlschrank aus. Da habe ich auch schon Kritik geerntet. Ja, aber du hast auch schon dagegen gearbeitet, denn du hast ja mit einem Strommesser gemessen, wie viel das bringt. Ich habe überlegt, wie lange muss er aus sein, damit es was bringt. Und das Ergebnis war? Es ist eine Stromersparnis, wenn er einige Tage aus ist. Jetzt komme ich nach Hause, mache den Kühlschrank wieder an, mache so die Dinge im Haushalt, hier, die sind so angefallen, deine ganzen Pflanzenwiesen, ich check die Glühbirnen nochmal alle, schaue, ob die Wasserhähne funktionieren, machst du das ehemals? Jedes Mal, wunderbar, setz mich hin und dann denke ich mir, ach nee, ah ja, ich habe ja noch tiefgekühlte Erbsen gekauft am Supermarkt. Die sind ja noch im Rucksack.
Aber wir sind immer noch in der Erbsenphase.
So, ja, ja, die habe ich ja noch gar nicht reingetan. So, dann gehe ich zu den Erbsen, will sie ins Eisfacht legen und sehe, da ist ein kleiner Eisbecher drin. Von vor? Genau. Zwei Jährchen. Von vor ein paar Tagen. Acht paar Tagen. der eisgekühlt war, dann schwand die Kälte plötzlich, er ist wahrscheinlich vollständig geschmolzen, einige Tage später steigt die Kühle wieder und wird wieder hart. Und jetzt stehe ich vor der Frage, ja was ist das jetzt hier? Schrödingers Eisbecher. Was ist das jetzt für ein Zustand? Solange ich den Deckel nicht hochhebe, ist es A. Ja, das ist die große Quizfolge. A. Geschimmelt. B. Einfach nur geschmolzen und wieder ... Ja, agilatisch und so. Die Frage ist doch eigentlich, wie lange dauert es zu schmelzen? Genau. Erst mal, wie lange dauert es, bis die Kälte überhaupt raus ist. Ich glaube, das dau raus ist. Ich glaube, das dauert sehr lange. Also ich kam nach Hause, habe den Kühlschrank angemacht und am nächsten Tag habe ich den Eisbecher gesehen. Das heißt, jetzt war natürlich für mich, also ich wollte, nur um hier wirklich völlig ehrlich zu sein, ich wollte den Eisbecher verzehren. Das kam durch. Und jetzt ist natürlich mein Wille massgeblich darin zugange, meine Überlegungen zu beeinflussen.
Das kennen wir alle aus wissenschaftlichen
Arbeiten. Wir alle wollen unsere These
bestätigen. Und dann dachte ich mir auch,
ich habe ja nicht gesehen, wie
das alles passiert, das geschmolzt
und so. Ich habe mir überlegt, kann
ich das nicht einfach aus, weil natürlich
unabhängig davon, ob er jetzt tatsächlich schlecht geworden
ist oder nicht, denkt man ja, wenn ich
den jetzt esse mit der Erwartungshaltung, der ist schlecht,
wird es eh schlecht.
Also da... Kann ich das nicht einfach aus, weil natürlich unabhängig davon, ob er jetzt tatsächlich schlecht geworden ist oder nicht, denkt man ja, wenn ich den jetzt esse mit der Erwartungshaltung, der ist schlecht, wird es eh schlecht. Also dachte ich, ich muss das jetzt einfach vergessen, weil ich habe es ja nicht gesehen, ich habe ja nicht gesehen, was passiert ist. Ich mache diesen Eisbecher jetzt einfach auf, als ob der ganz normal nie irgendeine Hintergrundgeschichte hat. Es ist nämlich ein bisschen ... Ich war jetzt mit zwei Kumpels unterwegs und es hat geregnet nachts und der eine Kumpel musste mit dem Roller wegfahren und der andere Kumpel, ich stand noch da, haben uns verabschiedet von dem Kumpel, der mit dem Roller weggefahren ist, wir haben ihm so nachgeguckt und noch gewunken und dann haben wir uns vorgestellt, was jetzt passieren würde, wenn er ganz hinten am Ende, wo er fast, wo man ihn fast nicht mehr sieht, weil er um die Ecke fällt, einen schlimmen Unfall hat. Und dann haben wir beide überlegt, wir könnten einfach gehen und so tun, als hätten wir das jetzt nicht mehr gesehen. Und das ist genau wie du. Man kann natürlich sich als Mensch immer ganz gut so vorstellen. Man kann Dinge ungesehen machen. Und dann haben wir uns beide vorgestellt, wie wir dann beide so nach Hause gehen mit einem unguten Gefühl, wir haben es nicht mehr gesehen, und dann nachts beide so aufwachen, nicht schlafen können, nachts so wälzen. Und sich dann so unsicher sind, ob er wirklich gestürzt ist oder nicht. Habe ich das wirklich gesehen? Dann schreibt man sich, haben wir das wirklich gesehen? Und nachts dann so, kannst du auch nicht schlafen, schreibt man sich dann. Der andere, nee. Und dann geht man wieder zu der Stelle hin, es ist dann schon drei Uhr nachts. Und dann liegt er noch da. Und er so, was so was? Robert, da liegst du ja, was ihr beide? Warum kommt er denn jetzt erst? Habt ihr es also gesehen? Weil es macht sonst keinen Sinn, diese ganze Geschichte haben wir uns vorgestellt. Das finde ich eine schöne Überlegung, wenn er zu weit weg ist, so dieses laufe ich hin, rufe ich einen Notruf und gehe dann. It's a whole thing. Es ist ja der ganze Nachmittag ist jetzt. Es ist so viel Arbeit. Ich komme da eh nicht rechtzeitig hin. Der Krankenwagen ist schneller da, als ich da jetzt hingelaufen bin. Ja, und es kommen Leute vorbei. Aber warum muss ich das jetzt derjenige sein? Nur weil ich der Freund bin, kann ich ihm doch nicht mehr helfen. Das ist doch Quatsch. Ich bin genauso wenig Arzt wie der nächste Passant, der da vorbeikommt. Vielleicht ist er ja ein Arzt. Aber deswegen verstehe ich dich so gut. Dieser Gedanke, ich habe nicht gesehen, was mit dem Eis passiert ist. Dann sitzt er da und dann denkst du dir nicht. Wie sitzt du dann da? Ja, vor dem Eisbecher und denkst dir halt so. Wie? Du hast dich dann in den Stuhl herangezogen. Ich nehme dich jetzt so, wie du bist. Mir ist egal, wo du herkommst, mir ist egal, was du durchgemacht hast in deinem Leben. Wir sind jetzt hier. Dir ist die Vergangenheit egal. Man kann nicht immer fragen, was hast du letztes Jahr gemacht, wer warst du letztes Jahr, warst du schon mal flüssig, was waren deine Aggregatszustände? Klar, der Mensch hat immer so dieses Verlangen, alles zu wissen über den Gegenüber. Aber ist es nicht auch mal besser, die Augen bewusst zu schließen? Ich habe lustigerweise jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen eine Stelle in einem Buch gelesen, wo es genau darum ging.
Da ging es um ein Paar. Und sie fand es besonders spannend an ihm, dass er nie ihre Biografie ausgefragt hat.
Was natürlich schon so eigentlich ein sehr frühes Ding ist, so ein zweites Date, drittes Date Ding, dass man sich so ein bisschen erzählt, wenn ich sogar schon erstes, woher man kommt.
So die ganze Biografie. Aber sie hat gesagt, sie fand das super cool, alles fiktional, aber ich finde dieses Gedankenexperiment gut, weil man dann alles, was passiert, bezieht man immer direkt auf die Vergangenheit. Man schafft wie gar keine neuen Erinnerungen, weil man alles direkt in Bezug setzt zu, was die, und das ist ja dann von ihm selber gekommen, die Biografie ist, die er sich selber quasi bereit ist zu teilen.
Und ich fand es super cool, dass man, und dieses Paar hat offenbar eine Beziehung in diesem Buch, wo sie immer nur quasi Happen bekommt aus seinem Leben, immer wenn es wichtig ist, immer wenn es um diese Themen geht. Und dann kann sie sich sozusagen selber ein Bild zusammensetzen. Also du musst über mich wissen, ich wurde mal von einer giftigen Schlange gebissen,
deswegen war dieser
Halloween-Prank mit der Schlange, der Gummischlange
unangemessen.
Und dann, okay, das wusste ich aber auch nicht.
Nee, wusstest du nicht, ich erzähle dir das jetzt.
Ich will ja dem anderen auch eine Chance geben, neu anzufangen.
Du willst, es ist ja immer ein neues Kennenlernen,
ist ja immer ein neues Anfangen, du kannst dich ja immer neu erfinden
als Mensch. Du musst ja nicht immer deinen Rucksack
mittragen. Und deswegen dachte ich mir,
mir ist eigentlich egal, was dieser Eisbecher
jetzt so durchgemacht hat, ob der im Knast war,
ob der im Knast war, was der
da vorgemacht hat, ich weiß, ich will jetzt auch nicht
ausfragen, ich nehme ihn so wie er ist.
Verschimmelt
und eklig und dann habe ich halt
Durchfall, na und? Ja und dann machst
du halt dann so die Folie ab
und dann denkst du dir, wie sieht Eis eigentlich normalerweise? Also, na ja, was ist jetzt genau, was ist jetzt meine Erwartungshaltung? Und dann plötzlich betrachtest du es auch wieder mit einem ganz anderen Auge. So, das ist so. Ja, super interessant. Also ich finde, bei diesem Gedankenspiel hat man jetzt, man hat auch zu viele Möglichkeiten, sich das selber zurecht zu rationalisieren, so wie man es braucht. Denn du weißt nicht, wie lange taut der überhaupt ab, der Kühlschrank, dann würde ich sagen, das Eisfach braucht noch mal länger. Fühlt sich auch noch mal dichter an. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Bei mir ist der Verschluss kaputt, ich habe ein Tape, unabhängig davon, ich will mich gar nicht aufhalten. Weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter. Nicht so Trimial. Und dann würde ich behaupten, dass die Temperatur in dem Eis, also quasi das Fach in dem Fach, dauert ja auch noch mal länger, bis es abtaut. Und was ist denn eigentlich Schmelzen? Und was ist Temperatur im Kern? Wenn was schmilzt und wieder gefriert, hat sich dann wirklich was verändert? Also jetzt mal gerne an die Chemiker und Physiker da draußen. Also sozusagen, ist noch jeder da, wo er vorher war? Oder sind die dann durcheinander gemischt worden? Oder ist noch alles da, wo es ist? Also sind die, vor allem die Schokoladenstückchen, gehen die nach unten oder nach oben? Oder was ist anders? Die schweren Dinge sinken am Gengrund, sinken rapide Gengrund, waren die schweren Dinge im Eise am Grund. Ich kam nicht so weit, ich habe ihn weggeschmissen. Also, du hast ihn dann herausgenommen, geöffnet, wie viele Löffel wurden gegessen, bis du ihn weggeschmissen hast? Null. Du hast ihn aufgemacht und dann nicht gegessen? Ich habe mit dem Löffel umgekratzt in die Oberfläche reingestochen und dachte mir... Wie lange? Wie lange muss man sich dieses Prozess vorstellen? Recht lange. Ich dachte mir, so fühlt sich kein Eis an. Ah ja, interessant. Das ist jetzt was anderes. Aber es ist natürlich subjektiv, weil du weißt in dem Moment nicht, wie sich Eis anfühlt. Du hast ja keine Kontrollgruppe, wo du jetzt sagst, so fühlt es sich an. Du weißt ja nicht mehr, was ist echt und was ist unecht. Das ist genauso wie wenn du jemanden triffst und sagst, hey, ich stell dir meinen Ompel. Was ist ein Ompel?
Hä, Ompel ist der Vater des Onkels.
Opa, Onkel.
Der Opa des Onkels. Das ist ein Ompel. Das ist jetzt auch egal. Also das ist Ompel Udo. Nur dass du es weisst, er ist da recht empfindlich. Ich kann mich nicht auf die Geschichte kurz drücken. Wie heißt denn das Pendant auf der weiblichen Seite? Eine Tompe. Tampel. Eine Tante und ein Tompe. Also der Opa der Tante ist Tompa. Und Tompa ist Tompo. Also Tampel, Tompe, Ompel. Das braucht man sonst nicht oft, aber das ist halt jetzt der Opa meines... Und was ist die mütterliche Mutter des Onkels? Der Tampe. Nee, nee, das ist die, nein, das ist ja... Moment. Nee, nee, nehmen wir vier. Die Oma des Onkels. Es gibt vier von diesen, ne. Ja, also. Tampe, Tampe, und jetzt gibt es ja noch die Mutter. Ompe, Ompe, Ompe, Ompe. Ompe und Ompe, wäre ich zufrieden. Ompe, ja. Okay, unabhängig davon, ich stelle jetzt meinen Ompe vor, nur dass du es weisst, er ist da sehr sensibel, aber er trägt ein Toupet. Okay, nice. Und jetzt, wo du es weisst, kannst du ja gar nicht mehr bewerten, ist es jetzt authentisch oder nicht, weil du hinterfragst ja plötzlich alles, wie sehen Haare aus, was ist echt, was ist Realität, was ist die Wände an und denkt, ist es hier, ist es Truman Show. Habe ich selber, was ist eigentlich mit mir selber los, wer bin ich eigentlich, bin ich, Ompel, oder wer ist das?
Bin ich, das sind ja genau, bin ich überhaupt. Das sind die grossen Fragen.
Genau, wie sehr beeinflusst die Erwartungshaltung, die Wahrnehmung und so? Da kommst du ja nicht mehr raus aus dem Kreis. Man kommt nicht mehr raus. Man kommt nicht mehr raus. Ompel, tampel, dumpel. So und deswegen, so ist es mit dem Eis. Du denkst dir, das ist nicht Eis. Das war zu zäh. Das war so ein bisschen, also wie so. Gummihaft. Ja, so ein bisschen zäh. Da dachte ich, das ist nicht in Ordnung. Nur damit wir uns verstehen, wir reden hier, wir sind hier im Fachbereich Sorbet, ja, also jetzt kein Milcheis, ja, kein sowas in der Ecke, wo man sagt natürlich Milch drei Tage ohne Kühlung nicht gut, sondern Sorbet sowas in der Richtung. Aber auch das das war am Ende konnte ich, weil es soll ja am Ende Spaß machen.
Es soll ja beiden Spaß machen am Ende. Und wenn du dich nicht wohlfühlst und erst mal es sich komisch anfühlt, dann lieber weg.
Nee, dann erst mal weg, ja, okay gut, die Metapher, ja, ja, eben, also wenn du die Metapher sprichst, dann sagt es sich sowas wie wegwerfen.
Ja, ja. Es muss sich für beide gut anfühlen, es muss für beide passen, und wenn es nicht passt, wegwerfen, wegschmeißen. Das könnt ihr wegschmeißen, einfach wegdonnern, in die Tonne kloppen. Das könnt ihr euch ganz gut merken. Das ist in vielen Lebenslagen genauso sehr gut anwendbar. Nee, ich verstehe genau, was du meinst. Ich meine, jeder von uns kennt ein Eis, was man nicht aufgebraucht hat. Es ist ein bisschen angeschmolzen, wenn man vom Fernseher mal wieder bei Argo eingeschlafen ist, kennt man, und dann hat man dieses Eis noch, was unten noch vielleicht gefroren ist, oben, was schon ein bisschen angeschmolzen ist, man wacht auf beim Abspannen und dann macht man den Deckel drauf und packt es wieder ins Eisfach. Dann macht man es wieder auf und sieht natürlich auch oben, fragt man sich natürlich auch Fragen, was ist Eis, wer bin ich, was ist ich, ist Argo ein guter Film? Man stellt sich die guten Fragen. Warum habe ich noch nie das Ende von Argo gesehen? Ich weiß nicht, wie dieser Film, ich kenne den ersten Akt, ja gut, zweiten, weiß ich nicht mehr. Und dann fragt man sich natürlich, war dein Eis genauso, wie man das eigentlich kennt? Aber dann hast du die Sorbet, den Sorbet-Curveball geworfen, dann wusste ich Frage, die will mir nicht aus dem Kopf. Also, ich bade gerne. Aber seit einiger Zeit bade ich nicht mehr so häufig, weil das Wasser ist nicht mehr so heiß. Und deswegen ist Baden jetzt zu einem Luxus geworden für mich. Ich habe noch von meinem Aquarium aus der Aquariumzeit so ein Thermostat, ein Ding, ein Heizstab. Ja, das wäre wichtig. Und deswegen tatsächlich muss ich aktuell nachhelfen. Und zwar, es ist ein bisschen erbärmlich, aber wenn ich mir ein Bad machen will, dann koche ich nebenbei Wasser im Wasserkocher. Und während das Bad einläuft, schütte ich immer das kochende Wasser rein. Und da denke ich auch immer, was passiert jetzt mit diesem kochenden Wasser in der Badewanne? Verteilt sich das heiße Wasser, oder wird die Temperatur verteilt, aber das Wasser selber nicht? Nee, das geht gar nicht. Okay, fair enough. Also was verteilt sich jetzt hier? Bleibt es das Gleiche und geht woanders hin? Oder wie passt sich das jetzt an? Man sagt ja, Föhn fällt in die Wanne und du bist so gut wie tot, weil du kriegst einen Stromschlag, den du nicht aushältst. Aber baden in einem Meer, in dem ein Blitz einschlägt, ist okay. Da habe ich mich auch gefragt, was passiert da? Das ist ja ein bisschen das Gleiche. Wie verteilt sich der Blitz im Wasser? Kommt er überhaupt noch zu dir? Wird ein Blitz schwächer? Wahrscheinlich schon. Wahrscheinlich ist das die ganz einfache Erklärung. Ja, aber auch, also angenommen, du schüttest einen Liter Apfelwasser in die Badewanne. Bleibt der Apfelsaft so ein bisschen noch als Gruppe zusammen, wie wenn du als Gruppe auf ein Konzert gehst? Klar, reißt mal einer ab, geht mal einer weg und kommt. Klar ist mal einer zu groß und wird vom wütenden Mob nach hinten gedrängt. Das meine ich jetzt gar nicht. Natürlich geht mal einer sich Getränke holen für alle. Natürlich schliessen sich mal zwei ab, die vielleicht irgendwie gerade auf einem Date sind. Natürlich ist der Grosse, der abgehängt wurde von der Gruppe hinten plötzlich und wird verfrügelt von kleineren Menschen, die keine Lust haben, dass sie auf dem Weg stehen. Aber die Gruppe als solche, da bleibt ja schon noch ein Gruppelet zusammen. Meine Frage ist, hast du schon mal in die Badewanne gepinkelt? Ja, natürlich. So, dann weißt du ja alle Antworten. Aber da weiss ich auch nicht, ob es zusammenbleibt, so als Team, also so nach zehn Minuten. Das ist doch wie bei Quarks und Co. Angefärbt, lustigerweise, gelblich angefärbt. Man sieht doch, was passiert. So genau habe ich das noch nicht beobachtet. Ich auch lange schon nicht mehr, aber so als Kind. Schon nicht mehr. Aber als Kind hat man natürlich immer die Badegewein gepinkelt. Ja, ja, klar. Aber hast du am Ende noch eine Restgruppe übrig oder verteilen die sich sofort überall hin? Es kommt ein bisschen auch auf die Bewegung an. Also ist dein Badewasser still oder machst du wie ich auch gerne mal ein bisschen Strudel? Oder was ist, wenn du jetzt kochenden Apfelsaft in die Badewanne schüttest? Bleibt dann die Hitze beim Apfelsaft oder geben die Apfelmoleküle, die Isotope, geben die die Temperatur ab oder reissen die irgendwo anders hin und sind dann da wärmer? Das ist die Frage. Sind denn die so, können wir nicht mal so eine Wissenschaftssendung machen, wo wir uns so ganz lächerlichen Fragen uns annehmen? Ja, Verb ans annehmen. Auch das war falsch, aber ich habe mich zumindest entschieden. Man muss sich am Ende des Tages auch committen bei einem Satz. Aber weißt du, das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Weil die Wissenschaftssendungen, die gerade laufen, die kümmern sich für mich immer zu sehr um wirklich, ja um zu grosse Probleme. Die verstehe ich da nicht unbedingt. Aber das kriegt man, glaube ich, gut erklärt. Mal null anfangen. Wie damals unsere Frage, warum, weil Hautmoleküle sind ja die gleichen, Hautatome, was auch immer, woraus die bestehen, warum kann man die nicht einfach zusammendrücken?
Warum bleiben die nicht zusammen, wenn man die fest genug drückt?
Ich habe über Ostern in meiner Heimatstadt in Dortmund einen Hochofen, einen Stahl-Hochofen besucht.
Und da hat irgendwann der Führer dieser Gruppe die gute Frage gestellt, weil Stahl ist ein wahnsinnig anspruchsvoll herzustellendes Material und kann nur in Stahlöfen hergestellt werden.
Woher weiss denn der Kessel draußen, der aus Stahl besteht, nicht, dass er auch schmelzen soll?
Wer sagt ihm das?
Wer zum Teufel sagt ihm das? Finde ich eine gute Frage. Mal solche Fragen machen. Ja, ja, mal einfache Fragen. Ich glaube, wir müssen als Gesamtgesellschaft noch mal einen Jahrgang wiederholen. Also einfach mal zu sagen, okay, wir sind durchgefallen. Lass uns noch mal wirklich zurückgehen und noch mal bei eins anfangen. Nicht dieses immer weiterhens. Nicht bei eins. Da müssen wir in dem Marketing drauf achten. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber einfach mal einen Schritt zurück. Ein Jahr zurück. Einen Schritt zurück. Nochmal so, jetzt mal für alle, nur mal für mich nochmal. Was? Genau. Was war jetzt gerade nochmal? Weil es ist allen zu peinlich zu sagen, sorry, das habe ich nicht verstanden, können wir als Gesellschaft nochmal kurz langsam einen Gang runterschalten und mir das erklären. Nein, das klappt nicht, es wird nicht klappen. Ich glaube, womit wir aufhören sollten, ist Leute dafür auslachen, dass sie Sachen nicht verstehen. Das ist mir ganz wichtig.
Machen wir beiden nicht.
Beispiel ging letztens ein Tweet rum.
Nein.
Ja, ich bin ja so ein bisschen in so der Wissenschaftsbubble drin.
Bei Twitter.
Ging letztens so ein Tweet rum von so einer Amerikanerin, so einer ganz naiven Teenagerin, die einfach mal so, die hat sich so ein Diagramm gemalt mit so einem Vulkan und hat dann gesagt, warum können wir einfach Vulkane nicht einfach mit Beton zuschütten, damit da keine Lava mehr rauskommt und Probleme macht. Und das Internet ist ausgeflippt. Und dann wirklich, und dann wurde es so geschert mit so einem, und deswegen ist Schulbildung so wichtig. So alle haben sich über sie lustig gemacht und ich stand da und dachte, ja, ist doch keine so schlechte Idee, oder? Also warum ist das jetzt eine so viel schlechtere Idee als alles andere? Leute, ich meine, sorry, warum machen wir nicht einen grossen... Leute, wer erklärt es ihm? Ja, aber wirklich, erklärt es mir doch mal, wer erklärt es mir denn? Nee, ich meine, wer erklärt es ihm? Nee, aber wirklich mal, wer erklärt es mir denn? Ui, warum kann man die nicht einfach zuschütten? Ja, warum denn nicht? Warum kann man einen grossenorken? Lass mal weitermachen. Einen dicken Korken? Nee. Ich meine, selbst wenn die Lava dann rauskommt mit so einem Bump, dann haben wir zumindest ein bisschen Zeit gewonnen. Aber ich beobachte das auch gerade. Leute werden geschämt für gutes Wissen. Für gute Ideen. Für gute Ideen und gute Fragen. Denn bei TikTok ging ja jetzt viral, dieses, wenn man zum Beispiel ein Blatt Papier, Dina-4-Papier auf den Spiegel macht und dann hast du ein Portemonnaie oder irgendwas, was ein bisschen dicke hat und legst es dann auf das Papier. Kannst du im Spiegel von der Seite trotzdem das Portemonnaie sehen, obwohl dazwischen das Blatt Papier ist? Dann haben sich viele Leute, es war ein Amerikaner, der hat dann gefragt, how does the mirror know is there? Was vielleicht eine lächerliche Frage ist. Moment noch mal ganz kurz, du hast einen Spiegel und du legst das Blatt Papier an den Spiegel dran, du drückst es dran. Schnellt euch eine große Spiegelwand vor, genau, du drückst das Papier, die nach viel Papier, undurchsichtig gegen den Spiegel und legst dann in die Mitte dieses Spiegels einen Gegenstand. Aber wie legen, der ist doch an der Wand. Du drückst mit dem Gegenstand zum Beispiel das Dina-Vier-Papier gegen den Spiegel. Also alles berührt sich und du kannst dann, wenn du von der Seite guckst, siehst du diesen Gegenstand. Und die Frage ist, how does the mirror know it's there? Was ich eine lustige Frage finde und es ist natürlich auch irgendwie lustig gemeint. Und dann habe ich geguckt in die Kommentare, fand ich einfach spannend und dann waren, es war ein amerikanisches Video und die Kommentarspalte waren nur deutschsprachige, nur deutschsprachige Menschen, die gesagt haben, die gesagt haben, haben die schon mal was von Physik gehört? Typisch Amis, haben nicht mal was von Physik. Und was lernen die eigentlich in der Schule? Es wurde dann so ein bisschen casual. Dialektisch. Dialektisch gesprochen. Man hat sich sehr wohl gefühlt und sehr sicher gefühlt in dieser amerikanischen Kommentarspalte. Und ich fand das ein bisschen übergriffig. Erklär es doch einfach. Ja, total. Und die Antwort ist Einfallswinkel gleich Ausfallswinkel. So haben wir doch was gelernt. Du kannst von der Seite reingucken. Es geht nicht. Spiegel, das ist auch eine gute Frage, ein Kumpel hat mir neulich mal die Frage gestellt, wenn man sich einen Spiegel vorstellt, der spiegelt dich ja. Du siehst deinen rechten Arm, ist plötzlich links. Ach Gott, nichts ist oben und links, rechts Ding, ah, das habe ich nicht verstanden. Und die Frage ist, warum spiegelt er nicht auch oben und unten? Weil du bist spiegelverkehrt, warum bist du nicht auch auf dem Kopf? Und die Antwort ist einfach, weil Spiegel nicht so funktionieren, Die entscheiden nicht, was sie spiegeln, sondern der Einfallswinkel ist der Ausfallswinkel. Du siehst etwas, dann stell dir einen Strich vor von eurem Auge zu dem Punkt, den ihr im Spiegel seht und mal den wirklich zu dem Punkt, den ihr habt. Das ist das, was macht der Spiegel nur? Der Spiegel, der hat nicht von irgendwelchen Seiten irgendwelche Entscheidungen getroffen oder sowas. Aber ich fände es auch gut, wenn man vor dem Spiegel steht und sich fragt, hä, eigentlich müsste der doch auch oben und unten spiegeln. Und der Spiegel so dreht plötzlich das Bild so um so, oh scheiße, ja stimmt, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, schnell, flieh um, und dann so, äh, was? Und dann so, nichts, nichts, nichts, nichts, ich habe immer schon.
Auch wenn ein Physiker irgendwann mir sagen würde, ja stimmt,
eigentlich müsste es anders sein.
Eigentlich dürfte der das gar nicht sehen.
Und jetzt sind wir doch bei Heisenbergs
Unschärfe-Relation. So, da ist er doch.
Heisenbergsche Eisbecher.
Heisenbergsche Unschärfe-Relations-Spiegel-Eisbecher.
Denn wenn man Dinge
untersucht, ändern sie auch manchmal ihre Eigenschaften. Progress, progress. Früher haben wir bei Massagesessel Hotlines angerufen und sind nicht weitergekommen. Heutzutage, wir klären hier Dinge im Podcast-Uvo. Wir klären die grossen wissenschaftlichen Fragen. Ich finde es aber auch gut, wenn letzten Endes das einfach ein Fehler ist. Dass wenn die ganzen Universum ist so ein Computerprogramm, wo dann einfach
so ein paar Bugs drin sind, wo dann einfach so ein bisschen
ja, ja, ja, gib hier einfach eine Zahl ein,
das ist jetzt egal. So und am Ende
dann, vielleicht können wir dann auch die Welt
reparieren, dass wir dann sagen, nee, nee, wir machen es anders.
Dass wir selber
Atome bauen, die sinnvoller funktionieren
als die echten, weil wir sagen, so
wir machen jetzt unser eigenes Ding und irgendwann bauen
wir ein komplettes eigenes Universum, das nach unseren Regeln herrscht, weil irgendwie, wer auch immer das Erste gemacht hat, der hat da so ein bisschen geschlampt und geschludert. Ich kann es mir auch im Spiegel so gut vorstellen, das habe ich auch mal irgendwann mal in einer Podcast-Suche-Folge die Frage gestellt, wenn ich halt im Auto sitze, ich bin kurzsichtig gewesen, muss man ja jetzt sagen, aber ich konnte in den Rückspiegel gucken, der nur wenige Zentimeter von meinem Gesicht entfernt ist, und zurückgucken. Und trotzdem, und ich sehe es ja, trotzdem sehe ich ja die Umwelt unscharf. Dabei sehe ich ja Dinge im 50-Zentimeter-Radius, sehe ich ja gestochen scharf. Den Rückspiegel aber trotzdem unscharf. Warum? Kannst du nicht immer einen Spiegel mit dabei haben, den du im richtigen Abstand hältst, mit dem du alles sehen kannst. Richtig. Und dann auch die
Frage, ist die Brille ein durchsichtiger Spiegel?
Nur so.
Nur so als Bonus
oben drauf. Wirklich kurz,
während schon alle aufstehen und das Seminar
verlassen, einfach nur als Bonus, einfach nur
zu mitnehmen. Goodieback.
Am Ausgang steht noch eine Schale
mit ein bisschen Bonuswissen, greift rein,
das ist jetzt nicht das Beste, aber einfach mal oben, einfach mal Idee mit rein. Shower thoughts, hinterher. Genau. Antwort ist, Spiegel funktionieren nicht so, wie du denkst. Und damit lebt jetzt damit einfach. Denn sie spiegeln ja nur das Licht, was eh von ganz weit hinten kommt, was ganz weit weg ist und projizieren ja nicht irgendwie. Die merken sicher, was da gerade zu sehen ist, und zeigen es mir als Fernsehbildschirm, sondern es geht ja immer noch darum, dass ich das Licht sehe, was von hinten kommt. Ja, wir werden den Spiegel nie verstehen. Doch! Wir werden den Spiegel nie verstehen. Was für ein unbefriedigendes Fazit ist das denn? Wir werden es niemals verstehen, was da los ist mit dem Spiegel, wo kommt der her? Wo der herkommt? Weißt du, wenn man zwei Spiegel aneinander hält?
Spiegelland.
Sehen die irgendwas oder nicht?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Es ist zu viel.
Komm, die werden alle abgebaut von einem Berg, wo Spiegel entstehen, natürlich.
Ja?
Ja.
Aber der ist extrem verwirrend, dieser Berg.
Super verwirrend.
Stell dir vor, die Leute, die im Spiegelberg arbeiten und in so einem unendlichen Spiegelkabinett, so ein unendlich langer Gang, wie so Kristalle, alles spiegelt und du checkst einfach gar nicht, wo du bist, hinten und vorne. Ist das dein erster Tag hier? Mit wem, mit wem wäre ich hier gerade? Hier, hier hinten, hi, hi, Tom. Achso, ich bin hier oben, ich bin hier oben, nein, du redest mit meinem Spiegelbild. Ach sorry, okay. Passiert eigentlich nicht ständig am ersten. Okay, sorry, Entschuldigung, ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt. Hi, hi. Warum bist du oben? Hi, ich wollte dich nur begrüssen, da oben ist die Treppe halt. Ach so. Komm einfach hoch. Moment, die Treppen sind auch gespiegelt? Alles ist gespiegelt, wir sind im Spiegelberg. Moment, laufe ich jetzt runter oder hoch? Du musst aufhören, dir viele, Regel Nummer eins, aufhören, dir viele Fragen zu stellen. Komm einfach, folgt meiner Stimme, Stimme, Stimme, Stimme, Stimme, Stimme. Komm hin. So, also hier, das ist die Spitzhacke. Ja. Die nimmst du schon mal. Und dann hier das Kopfhörer auf. Moment, jetzt greife ich in die Leere. Einfach hier, die ich dir reiche. Ach so, wer bist du jetzt? Kann der echte, kannst du mal winken, der echte mal bitte. Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom. Kann der echte Tom mal winken, bitte? Hier, ich wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, wink, jetzt, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Nein, wissen wir es alle nicht, aber du schlägst dich nicht wie Voodoo. Nicht, wenn du den Spiegel abschlägst. So, wie, ach so. Aber dann die kompletten, ganzen fertigen Spiegel raus, oder wie gross ist das? Naja, wie auf deinem Auftragszettel steht der jetzt gerade, was steht da gerade drauf? Umdrehen. Ach so, okay, Entschuldigung. Ah, das Spiegel raus oder wie gross ist das? Auf dem Auftragszettel steht der jetzt gerade, was steht da gerade drauf? Wo sind die, wo sind die, wo sind die, wo sind die, wo sind die, umdrehen. Ach so, okay, Entschuldigung. Ah, das Spiegelgranulat wird am Ende noch mal eingeschmolzen. Genau, richtig. So, dann siehst du da oben, Familie Smithers, möchte diesen Spiegel haben, ne, 50 x 50. Ah, schön. Genau, so, jetzt nimmst du die Spitzhacke und schlägst ihn einfach aus dem Spiegelberg hinaus. Das ist der letzte Spiegelberg hier in Südfrankreich, wo wir noch wirklich authentische Spiegel aus der Natur abbauen.
Schön, ja, ich mag das.
Aber Sie müssen zur Seite gehen, sonst hau ich auf Sie drauf.
Okay, nee, ich steh hier oben.
Nein, im Ernst, sonst, Sie müssen ...
Ich kann jetzt nicht auf Sie draufhauen, Sie müssen zur Seite gehen.
Nee, Sie müssen den Berg hauen.
Moment mal, ach so. Ja, das ist der Berg. Ach so.
Ding.
Ding. Warum aber nicht alleine eigentlich? Ist da sonst niemand unterwegs? Hallo, Tom? Ja, so läuft das da.
Ja, so läuft das. Es ist ein furchtbarer Ort. So läuft das da. Galileo-Beiträge werden noch immer. Die Galileo-Gamera-Crew ist so verwirrt, filmt sich ständig selbst, alle sehen sich selbst, filmen Leute ständig, die nicht da sind, sondern nur das Spiegelbild. Das ist eigentlich ein geiler Sketch, oder? Mont Miroir, der Spiegelberg in Frankreich. Und man geht rein und es ist einfach so ein Spiegel. Und alle sehen auch so dick und langgezogen aus und gleich. Und die Kameraleute sehen auch sich konstant selbst und man kann nichts filmen, ohne sich selbst zu filmen. Anstrengend. Eigentlich sieht man die ganze Zeit nur ein Kamerateam in diesem Beitrag. Spiegel sind schwer zu filmen. Ich hätte neulich die Idee. Natürlich auch ganz kurz, wie unser Ebay-Exkurs, wenn man bei Ebay-Kleinerzeigen nach Spiegeln sucht, sind die Bilder natürlich immer sehr lustig. Ja, ja, sehr lustig. Weil die Leute immer versuchen, nicht selber auf dem Spiegel zu sein, sondern nur ihre Kamera so reinhalten oder sich so eine Bettdecke über den Kopf legen. Aber man sieht natürlich nicht Spiegel, man sieht viel Wohnung, man sieht viel Kameras, man sieht viel Leute, aber man sieht nicht viel Spiegel. Und dann schreibt man so, können Sie mir nochmal ein Bild von dem Spiegel schicken? Das ist das Bild von der Wohnung. Wie stellen Sie sich das vor? Mütend, auch sofort, wenn du jemanden fragst. Kriegt diesen scheiß Spiegel nicht verkauft. Bitte fragt, das ist eure Hausaufgabe, fragt Leute bei Ebay, Kleinanzeigen lieb, ob sie ein besseres Foto von einem Spiegel machen können. Aber ruf nicht auf zum Prank. Nicht Prank. Ruf nicht auf zum Prank. Nein, Sozialstudie, weil ich möchte wissen, reagieren diese Leute ... Das werden wieder hundert Reddit-Posts, Stefan. Reagieren die Leute A, eher wütend, B, weil ich glaube, die reagieren sehr wütend, weil ich glaube, die waren mit dem Bild schon überfordert. Und wenn die denn fragt, könnt ihr noch ein Bild schicken, ein besseres Bild vom Spiegel, sind die sofort auf 180, ist sofort ein, ja, ihr habt es auch probiert, und es geht nicht. Ich glaube, niemand schreibt zurück, ja, ich könnte es mal versuchen, ein besseres Bild, weil alle hatten schon ein Problem, niemand hat damit gerechnet, dass es ein Problem wird. Ja. Fuck, ich habe heute Chili geschnitten, sorry. Hör auf, dir ins Auge zu fassen. Ich lerne es auch nicht einfach. Warum essen wir Dinge, die einfach offensichtlich schlecht für den Menschen sind und wo man sich nicht mehr gehörig die Augen reiben darf? Vor allem, weil du dir, du willst doch eh nicht die Augen reiben. Hört auch auf euch, die Augen zu reiben.
Man müssen Leute, alles was irgendwie exposed ist,
draußen am Körper, müssen Leute immer anfassen.
Warum müssen Leute immer alles anfassen?
Oh, fuck.
Ich hätte noch nicht die Idee für eine Sketche Idee,
für eine Late-Night-Show. Kann irgendwer machen.
Gebe ich jetzt hier Creative Commons,
gebe ich es ab.
Weg damit, Studio.
Und zwar sowas wie Nilpferd, Nashorn und Co, diese ganzen deutsch, typisch sehr der deutschen Zoo-Documentaries, die es ja gibt. Das halt aber im Jurassic Park. Also so richtig Jurassic Park, krass, es gibt die krassesten Lebewesen der Welt, riesige Brachiosauren. Die sind animiert oder? Das muss man ja gar nicht sehen. Kostüm muss man gar nicht sehen. Oder fahrt hier in Köln halt zu dieser Jurassic World Scheiße, dann können die das mit euch machen. Die suchen übrigens gerade wieder Ranger. Mir wurde sehr oft auf die Stellenausschreibung geschickt. Ranger gesucht. Nicht mal Schauspieler gesucht, sondern Ranger gesucht. Das heißt, die HR-Abteilung spielt auch dieses weirde Rollenspiel, habe ich dann gedacht. Niemand hat auf, um das Rollenspiel zu spielen. Kriege ich dann auch einen Arbeitsvertrag für Ranger? Und du schreibst dann auf deinen Lebenslauf dann auch so Jurassic Park 1984 drauf, weil du in der Rolle bleiben willst, oder was? Woher das auf? Ich hab immer schon mit Velociraptoren gearbeitet. Ja, und dann so, ist aber schon ein Schauspielerjob, oder? Und sie sagt, nein, wir suchen Ranger. Ich bin kein Ranger, ich bin Schauspieler. Ja, dann sind sie feiert, wir sind schon keine Schauspieler. Ja, aber welcher Ranger fängt denn hier an, in diesem Schauspielerjob zu arbeiten? Ja, wir suchen echte Ranger, die schon Erfahrung mit Dinosauriern gehabt haben. Haben Sie schon mal einen Velociraptor in der Hand gehabt? Nein, niemand, niemand. Haben Sie schon mal einen Schliebursaurus geführt? Nein, niemand. Das ist ja falsch, Entschuldigung, dann können wir hier auch direkt abbrechen. Ja, aber wie weird ist das ausgeschrieben? Das ist so merkwürdig ausgeschrieben. Einfach zu viele Leute in der Rolle einfach. Irgendwann sind alle in der Rolle. Und dann möchte ich nämlich diese typische Stimme, weil es ist so ein Narrator, der macht das. Und der macht immer so, Lila, der Nason, das Nason-Baby ist heute müde. Tim versucht sie zu füttern, klappt wohl nicht. So was, so was, so. So ein Kram. Ja, und dann irgendwie, und dann irgendwie ganz ruhig so, oh, jetzt frisst der Dinosaurier, futtert der Dinosaurier mal den Wärter und nicht andersrum. Hups, kann nicht jeden Tag glatt gehen. Oh, da braucht er viel Zahnseide, um den Wärter wieder aus den Backenzern rauszukriegen. Und dann diese Wischer, immer diese Happy Wischer mit diesen animierten Dinos.
Genau, wir schalten nach Jurassic Park Potsdam.
Genau, und da ist dann aber jemand irgendwie, oh, Mila, die Stegosaurus-Dame, macht heute ein paar Probleme.
Schreie, schreie, schreie.
Man kann da wohl nur zu sagen, das Leben findet einen Weg. Nach Dresden. Währenddessen in Berlin. Zack, Dresden. Die Terotaktyldame ist auf den Kirchturm geflohen. Werther Amin versucht sie wieder runterzubekommen. Ja, wir versuchen sie jetzt mal hier ein bisschen mit diesem Stott irgendwie runterzubekommen. Aber es ist halt nicht einfach. Man muss ja auch darauf achten, dass man sie an den Flügeln nicht trifft, weil dann können sie nicht mehr fliegen. Es sind halt große, teilweise bis zu drei Meter lange Spannweite haben diese Tiere und wir müssen halt gucken, dass wir jetzt hier, Nina, kannst du mir kurz helfen mit diesem Stock, sie irgendwie hier runterzubekommen? Oh, und da pickt die Terratyldame Nina die Augen aus. Da kann man nur sagen, Augen auf bei der Berufswahl. Aber ich finde das hilarious. Warum macht man das nicht? Ja, schwer umsetzt. Man muss die nicht zeigen. Ja, nur so ein großer Schnabel. Ja, finde ich gut. Oder die Geräusche. Macht die Geräusche. Ich finde das lustig. Mit so super trocken deutsch einfach mal so Jurassic Park. Aber gibt es ja nicht eine Audio-Schshow? Pterodaktyl, Stegosaurus und Co.
Und immer Pterodaktyl.
Die Pterodaktyl-Dame hat heute einen schwierigen Tag.
Aber wie wär's denn mit einer Audiosketchshow?
Ja.
Kein komplettes Leben überdacht einfach.
Da ging's nochmal ganz zurück in die Kinder.
Und so, Mama, Mama, Mama, warte auf mich, du hast mich vergessen. Nein, die Mama fährt jetzt alleine weg, die kommt jetzt so schnell nicht mehr. Währenddessen in der Grundschule. Der kleine Stefan muss heute an die Tafel. Na, ob das klappt, ob das gut geht. Fünf mal fünf, was ist das wohl, der Stefan weiss es nicht. Das müsste er eigentlich wissen. Warum schreibt er denn eine vierundzwanzig an die Tafel? Der erste Kuss kann für Menschenmännchen manchmal eine grosse Herausforderung bedeuten. Stefan gibt hier sein Bestes. I, was machst du denn, Stefan? Langzungen, Stefan, er heisst jetzt ab jetzt Langzungen, Stefan. Ich satt sie alleine im Schlafzimmer. Leute, er heisst jetzt Langzungen! Na, das hat wohl nicht so geklappt. Wieder in der Gegenwart. Stefan, wollen wir nicht ein Audiosketchshow machen? Ja, können wir gerne machen. Können wir gerne mal versuchen. Alles in Ordnung? Hast du auch Chili gekocht heute? Du hast irgendwie alles rote Augen so ein bisschen. Chili geguckt und mir sind ein paar Schnipsel aus meiner Vergangenheit eingefallen. Aber es ist nicht so wichtig. Gut, ansonsten wünschen wir euch alle eine gute Woche. Undh, ja. Nee. Nee. Ich haue jetzt jede Woche so eine Sketch-Idee für irgendeine Late-Night-Show raus. So lange, bis eine angenommen wird, oder was? Nee, einfach weiter. Es muss immer weitergehen. Wir hauen das einfach raus. Podcast-Ufo provided Creative Crumms. Übrigens, Creative Crumms. Wir legen eine Brotspur, eine kreative Brotspur, und wir schauen mal, wer uns folgt. Creative Crummons. Jetzt hier Baywatch Berlin oder Late Night Berlin oder sowas, die machen jetzt auch den Eurovision Gag Contest, den wir mal vor ein paar Jahren hier gemacht haben. Ja, was machen sie als nächstes? Ein GIF Festival? Ja, genau. Das gab es auch in Köln schon. Aber es ist uns egal. Uns ist das alles, das ist der scheißegal Podcast. Creative Crummons. Wir hauen die Krümel raus, damit andere sie finden. This ist Creative Crummons. Podcast UFO, Creative Crummons. Eine Initiative von Das Podcast UFO. Wir wollen einfach, dass die Fernsehlandschaft lustiger wird. Wollen wir dafür Geld haben? Gern. Ehrlich gesagt, gern. Ja, aber überweist uns gerne auf patreon.com slash das Podcast UFO. Und ja, noch hat niemand unsere Ideen benutzt, also tatsächlich niemand hat Interesse an den Ideen, also wir wollten nur nochmal sagen, ihr könnt die gerne nehmen, also die sind da, da liegt eine Schüssel, also beim rausgehen, nehmt euch gerne, nehmt sich einfach jeder ein, dann sind die weg und das ist auch gut, weil, also wir haben nichts dagegen, es kam vielleicht falsch rüber oder so, aber ihr könnt die von uns aus gerne gerne nehmen, also auch diese Duftkerzen, die dann so an den Filmen angepasst sind, nehmt euch welche raus. Je nach Film, dann riechen an die Szene angepasst. Wir haben gerade nur Argo, aber immerhin, wir machen gerade Ideen aus Verkauf, so ein bisschen, alles muss raus, überall sind Creative Grumens, überall könnt ihr was abfinden, das findet ihr schon finde ich stark kommt gut durch die woche ja kommt richtig gut durch die woche achtung vor dem dienstag kleines küsschen auf auf kommt das durch mal fühlt euch auf die Stirn geküsst kommt mal her küsst mal einen guten freund von euch gute Freund, gute Freundin, auf die Stirn.
Ich habe gehört, mir wurde gesagt, das ist respektlos ein bisschen auch, weil sich so über diese Menschen stellt.
Und das ist gerade bei Leuten mit deiner Körpergröße eine Herausforderung.
Nee, es ist einfacher für mich, Leute auf die Stirn zu küssen. Ja, aber überküsst zu werden ist für dich schwer.
Ja, aber ich, gerade Leute wie ich, die sehr groß sind, würden sich freuen, mal auf die ... Bietigen Platzarten. Auch von oben, so drüber?
Auf den Kopf küssen? Auch okay.
Okay, alles klar. Dann, ähm, hat eine schöne Woche.
Macht's gut, ciao. Ciao, Küsschen.
Steigen wir ein. Du zuerst, bitte, komm.
Danke.
Brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr